coach Prime I made it I made it ladies
and gentlemen I got Taylor here in the
house in Colorado I have made it my mama
was just here saying can you text my mom
and tell her maybe please I am so happy
to be here you thank you the draw
honestly I'm thankful that you're even
allowing us to be here so you know I
have been on the Dion wave a very long
time
interviewed everybody yeah so I know
once you're here I'm doing something hey
absolutely you're doing everything I'm
doing something you are the guy thank
you there's there's so much to discuss
I need to start with these sunglasses
and they hold special powers because
they do okay they do what are the powers
matter of fact I got you some
no you don't think I don't no I think I
know and I need you to rock them real
quick I got you oh girl
you feel good
yeah there we go yeah yeah be good yeah
they're great you like it I know I love
it put me in coach are you in
no but okay tell me what are the powers
they come with an essence of confidence
it's like a
it's like that Jenae Sequoia like you
know that you know that you know you got
that when you put those on it's it's on
it's like it's popping music just start
playing your theme music is playing and
they waiting for you to come down the
runway ready and then you're doing it
and I mean you know and you hear that
you know how the horse heals they're not
like you got up and down the runway and
everybody's like they can't even clap
because you they know you're killing it
and then they so insecure they look down
at themselves
and check themselves you know I
know I could wear my glasses got you
wear my chain I mean I don't know I had
all the things no okay so I have my own
that I'm gonna rock all the time but
where can everybody get these glasses
glasses
um blenders blenders blenders.com I'm
trying to make sure that they're
available but because I know they they
they're sold out right now but that's a
blessing that's a beautiful thing
because we have the black and the gold
pair yes no thank you so much for these
you have been just such a disrupter in
this space in the best way I think that
you have really made everybody pay
attention to what is going on
what was college football before coach
Prime came on the scene and what is it
now you know what I don't think
of myself as that I think of myself as a
person who's
unapologetically himself this is nothing
of the
ordinary that I that I that I do like
this is what I do everything I do I try
to do it extraordinarily so not
ordinarily I try to do it
extraordinarily I try to have a
commitment to Excellence I try to do it
with the way I do it with that Florida
that that that that that hits you know
that that confidence and that knowledge
based on study and preparation that you
can't you can't help but have confidence
because you're prepared so if that
causes people to be insecure so be it
I know you likely had the utmost
expectation of yourself coming here what
was that expectation and have you in any
way exceeded what that was I'm not never
gonna say we exceeded because I always
find there's more to do like I get up
probably about 4 40 every morning and
I'm probably in the office about 5 15.
something about that and I sit at the
desk and prepare my morning word and and
pray and find a a good inspirational
video for the team because we have
meetings at 7 15 that actually starts at
7 10. so I'm ready because I I want to
energize and encourage and motivate my
team as well as coaches and and set us
up on the right path for that day so
it's probably it's almost like the
navigation of that day we will have a
theme some type of theme of that day
that we must go out there and Conquer
what's been your favorite theme so far
this season personal
it's personal because that
that applies to Tom Dick Harry and Larry
and married too it's not just the
athletic thing it's so many things that
we're holding back and and people have
done we're so angry about yesterday that
we can't even focus on
today or tomorrow because we're crippled
and we're afraid so something that
happened that was personal has taken a
toll on us as p as a people let's just
take that power back it's okay to make
it personal because you got to have
something that drives you that propels
you that energizes you to injects you
you got to have something to that nature
but let's uh let's keep it tight and
keep it right because you got to remain
focused you can't get so emotional that
it gets you off balance yeah I never
allow emotions to provoke me to make a
decision and I never make decisions
based on emotions
so what is that balance then of knowing
when something does feel more personal
but not letting it sway you internally
yeah because when you when when it sways
you you start making decisions based on
those emotions and those emotions ain't
always right
it's not justifiably right sometimes
because it's the anger and anger is not
a component of the goodness of God like
you can't be angry and want to be
blessed simultaneously so you got to
just sit back and rock steady and say
okay now what what am I going to learn
from this what what can I glean from
this how can I Elevate from this and
once you figure that out and you learn
the lesson you'll stop stressing and
then attack the blessing so I want to
talk about that personal element a
little bit because it feels like to me
sometimes at least from my vantage point
that when people will critique you or
your team whatever they say it almost
always feels very personal it is but it
only gets personal with insecurity plays
a role it only gets personal when
someone feels that they're beneath and
not equal to it gets personal when
someone realizes that they're not
equipped with what you're equipped with
so now they gotta attack that that that
that problematic area in your life that
they think is your weakness and
oftentimes it's not even your weakness
you know something that you allowed them
to see so that they could attack that
but they're so far away from your
weakness that they have no idea and you
just sent this you sent them on a wild
goose chase do you know when you've
maybe made someone feel insecure yeah I
could see it I could see it and I could
hear it I could see it in their face and
I could hear it in their voice and uh it
becomes
so blatantly that because I treat
people right my mother raised me to a
point where I'm always respectful I'm
always smiling I'm always yes sir no sir
yes ma'am no ma'am and I want to find
out that one thing and you that makes
you smile to light you up you know I
want you to feel better about yourself
after we've had an encounter so I know
nine out of ten days I'm straight
so you ain't catch me on that one day
because I wouldn't let you catch me on
that one day because I'm not I'm going I
know me at this age and stage in my life
I know me I know not to come out when
it's that one day when it's that one
time when when you see me naked I'm not
gonna come out and allow you to do that
so I know how to handle me but when you
come at me like that that is a problem
with you yeah yeah well I mean it's been
a quite the three weeks for people that
doubted you yeah but you know what it's
been longer yeah it's been longer
actually it's been a few years because
what we accomplished in high school was
unprecedented I mean winning three state
titles what we accomplished and you even
youth football we won one all over the
country and then we go to Jackson and
and simulate the same thing so now that
we're here people were thinking that we
can duplicate what we did in Jackson
because Jackson they felt like when the
the level that they thought it would be
that would grant them their
uh a claim and affirmations but football
is football people are people young men
or young men and so it's the same
formula that we've been using for quite
some time and so I want to talk about
that football for a little bit you've
had three wins so far at Colorado I want
to talk about them all
when you think about the first one okay
against TCU yeah what did that win
represent we're here
it represented that hey hey we're here
stop overlooking us stop counting us out
stop doubting us we here
um you you can feel it you you they said
you could you could criticize it we're
here so that was like detention Grabber
that was like the trailer you know how
movies have a trailer that was the
trailer of the movie just getting you to
this movie getting you to the show
making sure you push uh on demand or
whatever you have you just click that
button and you want to see the real
thing that's what that was
that was tremendously personal and that
represented that I
like that I you you know when somebody
say something and and they they hit that
nerve in you and you say all right and
you know and then African-American
vernacular all right could mean a
multiplicity of things so it was like
that all right all right all right and
we went out there and uh did what we're
supposed to do at the crib at home and
it was that
I we we ain't playing like we told you
we we here now we ain't playing
win number three against Colorado
resilience
resilience because first of all you have
two
magnificent wins back to back of that
nature then you try to keep the team
rocking steady because not everyone in
the locker room including coaches have
won in their careers in their lives so
you got to sense that and you got to
feel that and you got to try to
find a Common Thread to bring everybody
and keep everybody together as one don't
let no one get too high or too low and
bring them all together but you know
some of them some are gonna go out there
well beyond the point because they've
never seen this much attention or this
much Focus or this much love or uh these
this many followers in one week
and you know sooner later you're gonna
have a hiccup
and I knew we would have a hiccup I I
wanted to beat them down and blow them
out but I knew as a coach the way we
practice the way we prepared that week
we're gonna have to fight and we didn't
learn from that resilience that we are
resilient we got some players that
really take this game serious we got
some darn good coaches but we got some
Personnel that that we gotta flip we got
to change
eventually but we got the majority of
those men on that field
they want to win and they love to play
this game and they love all the extra
that comes with it
so despite
all the talent on this team as I was
prepping for this interview and I would
type in Colorado football
one of the things that auto fills is
over hyped okay asking is Colorado
football we don't hike ourselves I mean
we Chronicle everything I keep receipts
everybody knows that I mean my son is
brilliant at that
um uh shoot Brian video we're doing a
great job with the documentary I mean we
do that because that brings attention to
our team and to our fans allow everyone
to know the struggle and the challenges
that we go through every everything is
just not Rosy but I don't feel that
we're over hyped I feel that we were
underestimated if anything
yeah and you feel like the talent on
this team does reflect the height that
your team receives yeah I mean the
talent is tremendous we got some guys
that are definitely going pro I don't
think that happened around here in quite
some time we don't have not one single
practice what does several Pro Scouts on
board
right now are you living in your purpose
oh I'm dugging in my purse
prepping uh moonwalking I'm doing a
Cabbage Patch whatever whatever the
dances they have now but I'm doing all
that because not only can in the midst
of a crowd in the midst of noise I can
hear God's voice I can just whisper so I
know his voice but not only that I'm a
father simultaneously
how can I get upset with anything that's
transpiring well now I'm not only
coaching but I'm fathering and not just
mine
I'm fathering a multitude of kids that I
adore that I this ain't work to me
this is a calling to me this is a
beautiful journey to me this is this is
what I dreamed of this is what I I I I
told the Lord I want it and he gave it
to me the reason he gave it to me
because he trusts me
trust that when you allowed me
to do my thing and to walk in my
anointing with all the the thoughts and
the visuals and the expertise and the
knowledge and wisdom that you gave me
you know before they write the story I'm
gonna give you the glory oh that was
good that was very good hey come here
come here
appreciate that
was very good very true is that some
kids choose a university but these kids
choose beyond what does it mean to
choose Dion
um
I think a multitude of kids choose to
coach especially when it's a prominent
coach that have had success in their
careers you could
play play oh you want to and say they
chose this universe no no they signed up
there because coach Nick Saban is a
winner and guess what he does he is a
pipeline to the NFL so you can say all
you want you chose this universe no you
chose coach Saban and I'm honest I just
had a parent asked me the other day she
said you do you think that
you know if you left that what you've
created is is still uh what was the word
like sustainable sustainable you go girl
I got you you know that she's smart too
right sustainable I say no Mom you're
right
I'm not gonna lie to you I would cry to
you for a lot to you but it's not
um God anointed me for this time this
season this this this this this this
this this era this moment he anointed me
for this and to coach your son and his
son and his son that's what God has
anointed me to do so this is my calling
so no I don't think it is
so knowing that right knowing that in in
some ways you you are the magic is there
like a pressure that comes with that
thing I'm not gonna say I am I would say
we are okay because the most uh
the most beautiful thing that we've
done here and I think it goes without
saying and a lot of people don't
recognize it is we've
built a tremendous staff
Bible consistently says thyroid and that
staff that comfort me I'm comforted by a
tremendous staff I was comforted by a
tremendous staff all the way from youth
all the way up through Jackson and now
here and I love these guys and I got
like-minded men I chose men that are not
only knowledgeable but not only
relatable and have relationships but men
that are great fathers why does that
matter coach Prime because how are you
going to be a father and a mentor and a
leader to these young men where you
ain't even leading your child
so that's a stickler for me it would be
no one on my staff it's not a great
father
because that means something to me
because they're going to see me with my
young men and young women my kids
oftentimes and they see how I am with
them so it's hard for me to understand
you trying to raise someone else's child
and you're not even raising your own
that's a problem for me and it seems
like a lot of the standards that you set
are just in line with life values yes in
what ways do the way that people live
their lives also mimic the ways that
they will play football coach you can be
an idiot off the field
yeah
you can be an idiot off the field not an
idiot on the field it
it don't work like that you can't
because you don't have the light switch
inside and you you you can't turn that
on and off you can't uh not study in
your school work and and bring back the
adequate grades so that you not only are
eligible but you are on your way towards
a degree and you ain't setting your
playbook
and that's why we look for a smart tough
fast disciplined young man with
character smart tough fast discipline
with character and we don't bark on that
we've made some mistakes and we've let a
few get slide but I promise you this
next recruiting cycle we ain't let none
slide because we've seen how that could
affect us and infect us so with your
approach being so all-encompassing when
this season is over how will you measure
success what has to happen for you to
say what we did this year was success
that's a great question let me tell you
something
um and all the comments and goings that
they've talked about in the
ignorant number of kids that have come
in and come out
we had the highest GPA in the history
of Colorado Football
in the history this spring with all that
going on
and right there now I clapped with my
feet
with my feet
that's how excited I was because I don't
play
bad grades of dysfunction in the
classroom because I'm wise enough to
know that 85 percent of these young men
ain't going pro
so I got to make sure they get the
education in their they're consistent
with the values of life because I want
them to walk out of hand with a
six-figure job and I'm trying to have
connectivity with several companies that
they can I Envision a Dern uh Workforce
draft
we have a NFL draft we have an NBA draft
why can't we have a draft for the kids
that play for me
into all these different companies
because they're smart to fast discipline
and they have character okay they may
not be a professional athlete they may
not complain for any of the leagues they
may not have that type of talent
but they have the ability in their
leaders
they have all these qualities that
translate in in leadership abilities
that translate into successful
Lifestyles because I want them to be
great fathers Great Men you know great
husband I want them to to just be
Community leaders I want to when they
come back to Colorado I want to smile
and say that that's about well I told
you you was going to be the governor one
day I told you that and I have several
of those young men that I could look at
I'm looking at them in my head right now
and they're going to be there
seen just believing and
[Music]
um
it uplifts them and it motivates them
um the Bible clearly says that it's life
and depth and the power of the tongue
and I use the tongue to uplift you I
mean when I say girl girl girl you see
what I'm saying like like that's
automatic and it's the same thing when a
woman looks at a man say you go boy boy
you boy you did that boy you did that I
mean and when I'm telling my kids uh we
had an instance on the sideline
um this last game with Jimmy was having
a horrific game he's a receiver Jimmy
horn and I said Jimmy you're a dog
from Florida man
and guess what pop is at the crib and
he's incarcerated watching you right now
and he wants to clap in front of all his
different inmates Because he believes in
his son we gonna make Punk proud tonight
that's what we gonna do because his son
is a dog now you go out there and show
the world who you are
and in return he went and caught the
touchdown the game tying touchdown and
he was having a written this night but
just speaking life into Jimmy and
understand where he was where he where
he was located I've been there because I
sympathize and empathize with him and I
know his background and his situation so
I'm able to pull that intangible out of
him that I connect to him in a pivotal
time like that and that's why I got to
know my I got to know my kids
I got to know this team I got to know
them individually as well as
collectively and those words have so
much power who
spoken life into you
um a multitude of people I mean playing
youth football this gentleman named
coach Capel came to the other side of
town and grabbed me Dave cable he and
his wife Helen uh he's gone to be with
the Lord now but his wife Helen is still
living what they showed me what they
introduced me to was a different way of
life because you know I lived on the
side of town where drugs were rampant
and the drug dealers was was stunning
doing their things and I seen a whole
nother sign on the other side of town
just on the other side of town and that
changed my life where I saw long
driveways and I had never I hadn't owned
a home in 15 20 years without a long
driveway because I always stay though
the longer your driveway the longer your
money
so that's exciting so that gentleman uh
what he did for my life uh
you know coach Ryan Hoover my high
school coach he was a disciplinary and
he was tough suspended me when I was a
junior because I got suspended
and it wasn't even my fault but I was
thankful because it taught me about
leadership
and how he didn't play favoritism I mean
when I went on to college coach Bowden
and Coach Vicki Andrews Mickey Andrews
was a disciplinarian as well a tough guy
but a fair guy and kept the stand the
standard in the main thing the main
thing was on your butt on that field but
time he got off the field how's the
family you know just cussed me out
now you're nice I mean but I'd love him
to like and I talked to him during the
bi-weekly about just my team and and how
to handle certain situations and just
onward and onward and onward to some of
the people that have really spoken into
my life I mean Bishop uh Omar Jawa was
my pastor that passed away a few years
back that really devastated me but he
was so
so critical to my
my calling into my knowledge and my
understanding of my calling now I got
Pastor Dewey Smith you know out of
Atlanta that's my dog and God couldn't
have given me a better man
um that Pastor Omar has left so he
when we have
coaches in life like in in sports that
gives us an advantage and I wish every
Tom Dick Harry and Larry had life
coaches because we've been tutored and
mentored by some prominent
really good people and that's why my
spiritual coach is everything to me yeah
because I want him to keep me straight
like I'm on navigational says you got to
keep me you got to tell me as they left
stay left and I stay left you know go
right go right I mean you got to tell me
again I got to hear that as well yeah
and I'm proud of that
so you have said that you save the prime
Persona to football
who is Prime who is Dion um Dion is kind
of recluse
um
com
very uh introverted really really very
introverted country boy with a city swag
love the fish
loves uh anonymity if you could believe
it um I want to pause there because I
think there will likely be a lot of
people that don't believe that yeah very
light anonymity and yeah very recluse I
don't like crowds
I I know how to show out in the crowd
but I don't really like because I don't
really function well in crowds and you
you don't catch me in crowds most unless
I'm in a game but you won't never see me
in that realm uh Prime is totally
different Prime is that Alter Ego that
we all have that I just have had an
opportunity to enact
to really put some legs on and make him
work because I told my mother you know
when I was seven She I was gonna make a
lot of money she was gonna never have to
work and I saw way back then defensive
backs they wouldn't slide it to do that
so I had to create something that I know
would and I created this character in my
dormitory room in Florida State and I
just fed him and fed him and fed him and
fed him and perfected him and uh it is
what it is so now I'm I'm probably a
blend
of both right now because I went from
Primetime to just Prime now coach Prime
is like I'm in the third quarter and I'm
winning and I'm half stepping so in some
ways was Prime sort of a Persona that
you had to adopt to be able to be
different from
um no it's something I had to adopt to
command
the resources that I promised my mother
cornerbacks and defensive backs at that
time didn't even make a meal
um
Pride made us a meal the first ever in
the history of the NFL in the first two
million in the first four million then
the kids kept going crazy so I'm
thankful I'm appreciative but you got to
understand I I
can't get caught up in trick or treat
365 days a year you can't do that
because you saw the lady you got to take
your costume and your mask off and be
who you are but see that's the thing I
know who I am like at this age and Stage
probably for the last 20 years I found
my location and I know who I am what I
am how I am where I'm going and I know
how to get there
so going off that way back and I think
1989 is when you said they don't pay me
to be humble right now it feels like
there are people that are almost calling
for you to be that yeah why is this idea
of knowing who you are not necessarily
being humble one of the things that
propels you
um
when I said that that was because I was
I was a grown dog got down that field
like I'm not gonna be
humble about what I got and the gifts
that I have
never seen nobody open the present on
Christmas and said oh that was so sweet
no oh you see what I got
all right I got a gift
that I've opened
and I'm thankful and proud of it you
don't think I'm gonna shout and rejoice
in in in in and do my thing because of
this gift that God has given me no
that's what I meant by that I got a
tremendous gift and I Know It gift and I
perfected it but hard work focus and
dedication
I also think when you're good at
something and you know you're good at
that thing for whatever reason it makes
people uncomfortable if you vocalize
that you're good at something and that
speaks to that insecurity maybe people
feel when they're talking to you because
they're like well wait a minute they're
supposed to not be all of this because I
don't feel like I'm all of you true
there lies the quote don't allow my
confidence to offend your insecurity
there lies the quote that's where that
quote derived from and I can't I can't I
ain't got nothing to do with that
whatever you're going through because
I'm gonna be me and I'm mandated to be
me I'm pleasing God not man now if I'm
pleasing God and God is having you
tripping that's a problem with you that
ain't me because I all I want to hear
God say is well done my favorite servant
and I've heard him say that a
multiplicity of times so you got a
problem and that ain't on me that's on
you it ain't on me that's on you yeah so
you did this article in the 80s and I
want to read the questions
it's a great quote that applies to you
right now which is why I loved reading
it so much
so this is in a sports illustrator
article you said all my life I've been
the man I've been in the spotlight at
every level it's just a bigger Spotlight
I learned the system in college how do
you think defensive backs get attention
how do you think Jim McMahon made so
many millions they don't pay anybody to
be humble some people will come out to
see me do well some people will come out
to see me get run over but love me or
hate me they're going to come out wow
I'm a businessman now and the product is
me Prime Time God does good so can you
put some hand claps in the edit
absolutely Give It Up
that was a young Prime but and I say
this to illustrate that this person you
are now is in so many ways who you have
always been true what comes to your mind
hearing that over 30 years later wisdom
I didn't know I had that type of wisdom
at that age because what people wanted
to see was pram I could remember and I'm
not gonna call the gentleman's name very
popular
um
personality television personality
interviewed me in San Francisco I mean
I'm defense player of the year we went
in you know we Super Bowl bound and he
wanted the interview Prime
and I gave him the uh
that interview never aired because I
didn't give him what he wanted
I gave him to you but he didn't want
that you should just told me you want
that and not just come to interview me
and then never aired so I looked at him
Sideways from dinner
yes so you you just wanted the puppet
show
that's all you wanted you ain't going to
get to know me because I'm trying to get
you me but you don't want me you won't
Prime you should have said that you're
one of the Persona instead of the thing
that was real genuine right so you're
saying how you said you know I know
people are going to come out something
to see me win something
and it's the same I feel like there are
some people that watch your games
because they actually want to see you
all lose that's right I think 9.3
million did
yeah half of that probably three
quarters of that wanted to see us win
it's a small portion of that wanted to
see us defeated but I'm cool with that
because in that process they get to see
all our kids yep and the sponsors get to
see our kids I mean potential nil is
good to see our kids so I absolutely
love it because
I could attract them but the kids are
going to hold them and I love that
what is your relationship with losing
we don't like each other
we don't get along
and we've never been friends
and we've never really kicked it
that dude called winning yes my dog it's
my homie hey that's my partner we know
each other well we've been together for
quite some time so I'm more comfortable
with him than I would ever be with him
because you never gonna see me with him
publicly but you're gonna always see me
with it you never see me on a post on
the gram or on Twitter or social not
smiling yep I'm gonna always put my
camera
I'm gonna always give you that because
that's the way I feel inside that I
wanted to project outwardly so I'm why
how I'm too blessed to be stressed I
like I enjoy life I love the life I live
and I live the life I love and people
get upset about that and I'm enjoying it
with my babies my daughter was just
laying on the couch in my office sleep
probably a couple hours ago because she
had a tough workout this morning and she
come right up there and give me a hug
and give me a kiss sit on my lap and
Wanna Be baby girl with her big self and
then she'd get on over on the couch and
go to sleep I love that my baby's right
there
you have everything that you would want
uh
any
so knowing obviously the success of the
program so far the fact that you get to
work with your children the fact that
the team is doing so well these are all
great things yes and I can tell that
because of this you are light you are
too blessed to be stressed
is there anything that does keep you up
at night
um underachieving
I'm a
perfectionist and I like to get the most
out of any situation
like any player come in and watch film
in my office by myself quite some a lot
and I go and say Mikey uh
why wouldn't you catch the ball your
legs automatically fold up
stand up don't do that
keep your your footing you're gonna get
more yards you're gonna be more
productive he said coach you know I
didn't notice that I see that those are
the little things that will take you to
the next level so
I want these kids to be successful man
I've had my turn
I've had my turn I want them to do it
and I'm going to be that
guy in the corner of that boxing ring
saying left right left I got this okay
this is what you say in the press
conference okay give them that all right
then walk away you know I I love that I
love this kind of stuff man but I want
these young men to be the best that they
can possibly be on and off the field
you've talked before about just the love
and respect that you have for Coach Nick
Saban yes you called him a teacher yeah
what are some of the biggest things that
he has taught you
um
identifying
personnel
coaching wise
um
understanding
the different
not leagues but the different
conferences
understanding all that language and and
how this stuff works and why this school
is going to that conference that this
school is going to that conference and
always being prepared for what's next
because there's no one that has lost
more coaches to the next level than he
has but it keeps on ticking why because
he's the engine he he is it so just
little things that he may whisper in
between takes when we shoot an Aflac
commercial they're sacred to me because
he is him
and I respect the heck out of him
this probably things we can't talk about
yeah
is there one that you can talk about
um plenty but I can't I can recollect
some right now but he is he is
he's the brand Marshall man he's the
magnitude laude to me I respect him
so darn much I really do
I really enjoyed watching you live
before your game
um on game Dan you said something that
was super interesting you said shadura
doesn't get the respect he deserves
because he's my son he does elaborate
more on what you mean by that yeah even
coming out if they would have just
looked at him coming out of high school
as a quarterback and he wasn't attached
to me he probably would have been the
five stars not that stars matter it
matters to kids it don't matter it's the
coaches and if they would have looked at
him just by his ability and disconnect
him from me when even when he's at
Jackson they were like oh my God this
kid's mechanics are unbelievable it's
it's completion percentage I mean his
touchdown interception ratio is crazy I
mean he's thrown 70 touchdowns in the
last during two years and he started
every game of his college girl they
don't look at that that's his son he's
giving him a pass he's giving him that
he's giving him the job at Colorado he's
doing this and not just understanding
who he is now
that he's on the main stage
oh my gosh your door is this and
everything we've been told you that
right and It's upsetting to us it is
upsetting to him because he he shouldn't
have given that chip now he has that
chip on his shoulder and uh that Brady
asked he's gonna find something to get
mad at every game and uh he has that
chip on his shoulder so then as a dad
before at this point
what was it like for you to maybe feel
somewhat responsible for the perception
of him
[Music]
we ride in that together
because even when he chose to come he
was going to FAU and the only reason he
was going after you was coach staggart
and that staff as well as
he wanted to start right away
he ain't going to sit on them bench he
said yeah how am I going to get better
sitting on the bench and I told him that
you don't get better sitting on the
bench
so he wanted to start right away because
he could have went to any any place
Alabama any place he desired to go but
he wanted to start right away so just
having him ride with me and we having
that conversation finally around the
house one day he said hey look at though
we gonna talk about this and we just
gonna play like it ain't now I said
let's talk about it because I never want
to say hey you going with me so I wanted
him to make that decision he said we're
going to do this or not I said cool
he's just gonna cost you a car though
so you're gonna hit your daddy up so you
gonna hit your own dad up
yeah
I know I you know I saw that clip of you
talking with your
uncle about okay what if what if she do
her leaves yeah we don't want to talk
about that
[Music]
you
know that we're never cut off guard or
anything and uh
Daddy has been around the block a couple
times so we discussed every possible
scenario that can be had with both of my
sons well we're on all three of my signs
because Junior you know he's he's going
to be up there photographing it and
doing his thing with it
so we we've talked about everything it's
no surprises Under the Sun with us
so I guess I'm curious for you what do
you have to see from a player to say
okay they are ready to make that jump
it's it's not about what I'm seeing from
them it's about
a whole lot of other things
teens position
um round projection all of that plays a
role because now with nil and who they
are
shoot you can make just as much money
here
in there unless you uh
you know one of the first five picks but
shadowy don't want to be too to nobody
you don't get down like that so you know
people projecting him behind uh you know
Kayla Williams and Caleb Williams is is
phenomenal but Shadow ain't no backseat
writer he ain't he you know he he drive
his Maybach he don't have a drive in he
drives it the moment you knew
seven
what did you see it seven as well as
Shiloh because hit in my phone he's up
on the ground like grown he's a grown
man he's very mature for his age he's
always been calm cool and collected he
was checking off at seven years old and
Daddy was over there calling the place
for him and grooming him and I taught
him all defenses first so he knew it was
covered too you know especially in in
Youth League they ain't playing with
cover three cover two and he was
checking off getting the ball down the
field like in no time that's why we
didn't Flinch last week that's why up
two yard line 98 yards cool minute 40
minute whatever it was on the clock cool
he's done that before we got that he
don't Flinch and he loves that that
those moments he loves those moments
what was funny was his brother came to
me and shallow say in overtime you know
and he rarely ever calls me dad on the
field he know him play that he's like
dead
you putting the defense out there first
so you only stopped nobody all day your
brother going out there and I know what
he gonna do I mean that was the attitude
that really happened that really
happened I know what he gonna do because
I like to put pressure on people I don't
like people putting the pressure on us I
know he's going to apply instant
pressure and he did you know a lot of
people obviously are watching and you've
mentioned Brady as care they always
compared to Tom Brady what football
player do you compare should order to I
don't look I don't do that with my kids
I ain't they ain't the second of nobody
they're the first of them we ain't we
ain't doing that
no no we don't do that are we Sanders
yeah we Sanders you know and when we
take that walk we always start off let
everybody in this world this country
watching this game know our last name
before we leave him tonight and what do
you want that last name to mean to them
um
success
a passion purpose dominance knowledge
commitment Excellence oh it's so many
different attributes that I could
continuously name but
what all that being said we're winners
we're winners
I at one point asked Jason Tatum this
question I'd love to his answer so I'm
going to ask you the same thing what do
you want your children to know about the
way that you love them
um
that it's uh
it's agape love it's uh it's a love
not based on reciprocation
I love them regardless they don't do
nothing for me Pat me on the back kiss
me on the jaw return the sentiment they
know I love them because love is action
to me love is just not language love is
action in
I've tried to show them throughout their
lives
action so shador has never until I went
down in having surgery she don't never
played a game without me
there Shiloh only played without me that
um when he went to uh South Carolina but
I've coached him football baseball
basketball all the way through all the
way up
um taking him to school in the morning
so picking out all their clothes you
know doing everything uh baby girl I
could raise some hat too you know get me
wrong okay don't play with me I'm from
Florida I believe you I could get down
so just just in teaching them
I had to be a man
how to be a man and and we get so
criticized of African-American fathers
by not being there so when we have
father's dinner there and when I see
them about even on social I give them
love I give him the flowers right there
because I love it I absolutely love it
and I adore it but my kids
um I've always said I'm not perfect but
I'm darn show present I'm darn show
present absolutely I believe that
you know one thing when I was growing up
that my parents would always do is
tell me about the mistakes that they've
made the things about them that they
don't want me to be like and also the
things about them that they do want
what are things about yourself you want
your kids to reflect and things that you
want them to actually be better at
um choosing
um people that they spend time with
that's that's that's number one don't
let anybody and everybody in your
company and everybody that's there ain't
necessarily there clapping for you or
clapping with you or wanting to see you
succeed
um I pray and I tell them about
discernment of situations and things I
can't just police them 100 of the way
and they got to grow up but
as much conversation and affection I
could give them like we just had a
tremendous game and it was late I
canceled practice on Sundays I said we
spending time together all my boys we're
going to the Bronco game we're going to
eat brunch then we're gonna go to the
game and that's what we did because
I'm not stupid enough to think that just
coach time is enough they need daddy
time
they don't need for both of them they
need a father too they're just going to
love them and and and and
Ugg Shiloh and say son I'm so proud of
you man
easy like that I'm gonna be there in a
few minutes but I got to go to church I
made a deal with God I said you can't be
cutting no deals with God
you make it a big play so you're gonna
go to church you have your butt there
next week too then do that
but that's shallow yeah I want to talk
about one of your other Colorado Sons
for a minute Travis Hunter oh my God
yeah I mean first off when you say his
name it's just like he's so he's him
good he's him he's him in every bit of
in every aspect he is him like we have
never seen someone like Travis
oh Travis loves the game
loves to prepare
loves to study he's in love with the
process of it and a lot of people that
are projected the way he's projected
ain't they just want it to be that guy
and they relied on
the story
to be told in them not working towards
it Travis wanted I think at 5 30 or 6
a.m every game day morning I get a text
let's go
and so we played tonight game so last
week he was late it was like came about
nine I said you late
let's go
he said I know he was tired I just
wanted you to sleep in yeah
I did this for you yeah but I I love him
to life yeah and he is
so complete as a player even as a person
Travis don't care about no jewelry
Travis don't care about no
high priced cars Travis want to fish
want to play video games want to spend
time with his his girlfriend
and want to be the best that he can be
that's who Travis is he's really
a he really he's like Deion really
he's like him he's really is in so many
aspects you know I think that a lot of
coaches would know that you are going
into this big game no that you won't
have Travis and they'd fret a little bit
but you see these facts next man up
because everybody want to be him until
it's time to be him now you got a chance
to be him
you got it man
okay but based on what I said practice I
know what I'm saying the game so if I
don't see it in practice you can't do it
in the dark and think you're gonna do it
in the light that don't work like that
so we have some tremendous challenges
this weekend I love it because they say
they want it
everybody want to be the man until it's
time to be the man and we're going to
see this week and I love that challenge
because we have a few that I feel like
is going to step up yeah and take that
challenge
so when you see you see a challenge
it makes you feel it makes me want to go
get it a lot of people want to wait for
the challenge to get there I go get it
yeah I'm gone I'm going to get it I'm
forward thinking I'm I'm Progressive I'm
I'm I want to go go dominate that down I
want to go swing on that thing like uh
let's go yeah and don't wait for it you
ready right now let's go get it yeah
yeah I know you talked about obviously
the fact you're like I've had my
Spotlight I've had my time before rap I
gotta talk a little bit about
Dion Sanders on the field because you
know I'm a Falcons fan I have obviously
been a big fan of you for a very long
time but there's just a few Legendary
Moments you have had that I would love
for you to discuss uh the first being in
92 and you attempted two sports in a day
did it you were in Miami then you went
to play for the Braves in LCS right tell
me that story and how that even happened
that happened because I had a football
contract that I had to uphold and I
wanted to uphold because my football
teammates is something that I was
contracted to play as soon as the
baseball season was over so the playoffs
just being there was just extra for the
Braves because my contract was over so I
was just going over there just to help
my teammate so I should have been
playing football the whole time so I'm
sitting on the bench for nine innings
and I'm sitting up there trying to
reconcile in my mind
this ain't right my guys getting ready
to go play Dan Marino
and all those wonderful receivers and
I'm sitting on the bench for nine
innings that don't that that ain't that
ain't right so I said I gotta go I got
to play with my guys so they made
Transportation Nike did of course and I
was able to get there and get back well
before the game was going to start they
weren't gonna play me anyway and I knew
that and they didn't play me anyway so I
actually didn't play two sports on the
same day I showed up to two to two you
know and played in one and we we lost
but
we probably would have lost by much more
than we lost by with the Falcons but
just being there for my team
was everything to me it put me in tears
because when I got on the bus they
didn't see me the night before I think I
got there two or three or four in the
morning but when I got on that bus that
next morning they applauded and that
broke me because it was like their way
of saying
thank you my dog I appreciate it and
that was one of the most touching
moments I've ever had in sports that
wasn't those teammates applauded
what do you think about that moment made
it so special
um Love
they showed me love
they showed me love because they know I
didn't have to
and they know everybody would have
understood if I didn't come because I
had
a big official over here in the in the
playoffs because the playoff regular
season game you know you can't compare
the two at that time but I did because I
was more needed in uh football
you know it seems like and from what
I've heard when I've talked to people
people might have whatever word to say
about you but there's nobody that says
you're a bad teammate oh because I what
if they did they lied or this is
something something underlining in there
yeah yeah it's just something something
else that transpired it they don't want
to talk about in that so I've never been
there and uh I've never spoken
negatively to my opponents you know I
was known for talking and talking and
being Brash and I wasn't I never talked
to my opponents I never they saved my
opponents I never down my opponents a
ridiculed them never whatsoever
trash talk my game was too loud both of
us couldn't talk my game was so loud
baby we couldn't talk at the same time
never I never talked to nobody I didn't
believe in that I believe that that man
worked his butt off to be in the NFL
how can I down him and then this was my
philosophy as well
why would I Trash Talk a down my
opponent if I'm gonna do anything just
being the psychological aspect of it I'm
gonna lift you and lift you and lift you
and Elevate you so that when I whoop you
I'm whooping a king and a giant not a
peasant if I down you and bring you down
and I whoop you they don't say you were
supposed to do that but no no no I
wanted to lift you up and then go get
you that was my thought process and that
also probably made it a lot sweeter too
yeah yes it did I know you said you're
never going to coach the NFL so I'm not
going to ask you no I'm not I'm gonna
ask in a dream world
who is one current NFL player that you
would like to coach
I would like that cheetah to play with
your daughter now but like hey hey I
would like that cheetah I would like
Kelsey to play with chidorah
and Shiloh
that
that's probably the two
what do you like I would like to see
sauce on the other side of Travis
you know
I would like that
but you know I have to stop right there
because I don't follow the NFL game like
I used to when I was working NFL I'm in
the college now so I'm I'm on that now
so I don't really watch the NFL too much
okay what do you like though about
Travis Kelsey about tyreik Travis Kelsey
is it man
I love everything about Travis Kelsey
man Travis council is like a little
brother to me man I I I'm serious like
he's like the guy I could call it
anytime they tell what you're doing and
baby I mean he's always in a good mood
and a dog and just dominates every
weekend and he has that Janae Sequoia
off the field as well and I love that I
love his brother too yeah and his mom
yeah that confident that that bleeds off
the field as well I love that but that
cheetah is
shoot he's so darn dominant man and it's
so and he's confident
and first of all you know I love all my
Florida boys you know that yeah yeah
all right now speaking of off the field
I know that you have been continuing
your docu-series coach Prime yeah what
have you enjoyed the most about filming
that here seeing uh the different
personalities on the team we have oh man
yeah I think we have a hundred and
fifteen hundred and sixteen something
like that on the roster maybe
something like that but seeing all the
different personalities and we're
pulling some out so you can get to know
them intimately I like that because it's
not I know the docu series it's called
coach Prime but it's not based on me
it's based on our journey and you being
able to see some of these young men that
uh we've we've brought into the fold
it's going to be very interesting man I
can't wait as well as the coaches yeah
now I can tell you love it you're
smiling because there's so many
different personalities I'm thinking
about several of them right now and
they're hilarious I cannot wait do you
see their personality especially Bishop
yeah Bishop yeah okay so we'll be on
lookout for Bishop yeah yeah Bishop is
something special Bishop is the kind of
guy Bishop tried to live here he tried
to live in the complex it's a very nice
complex but you know what Bishop said
Bishop said coach
I got 17 bathrooms I got a hot tub cold
tub I got 22 TVs
I said yeah of a dog you got to get out
you cannot live here okay what
you just got to get out there this can't
be home right you walk around with a
toothbrush
all right a couple more for you before I
let you go you've obviously done so much
player HBCU coach coach here also
baseball player with so many things like
what iteration of Dion
do you want to be remembered as
the greatest father to ever lived
the greatest father that ever lived if I
could be known as one thing
dead
end up I know baby daddy I'm telling my
dad yeah
yeah I pride myself on being a great
father I really do not only to mine but
to a multitude of these young men in
this locker room
there are some people that think that
this everything happening in Colorado is
a moment
why are you more than a moment why will
this last
um because
moments
that has consistency
translates into monuments
that's another one that was so good I
just had to think about that when I said
it I saw it God that was good
let me see if I can say that again
please do
moments
that are consistent translates into
monuments
and I'm a monument
not a moment
you see how it turned and gave you that
contact at the end that was like the
nail it that was like the exclamation
part like
[Laughter]
[Music]
and you know I know that your faith is
something that means a lot to you and I
know that music also means I love you so
I wanted to get a message from somebody
that combines both of those things for
you okay okay ready
you're Taylor thank you for giving me
this opportunity to show love to my man
yo what's up
man the conversations that we've had
over the years the way that I've seen
God continue to use your career uh
you know you're still not as cute as me
but you are that guy Dion you are my
brother we have had conversations about
God in the future in ways that so many
may not understand and I know that
that's the win that is forcing you to
continue to be great that wind of God
that just continues to blows uh in your
back and your family and your life and
now in the state of Colorado it's crazy
my god let's go King
salute
let me tell you something that brother
right there not only is a great friend
and a great man of God in a great man
period
he's arguably the best Entertainer to
ever hit a stage
he he is on electricity like when you
see like if Kurt played ball he would
probably be a slot receiver or a corner
you know that that because he so he
flies on or what but I love him so much
we have the most pure honest
conversations and uh I love him to life
yeah thank you absolutely thank you
absolutely that is my dog yeah no I
wanted to give you a little something
special because I'm very happy that you
allowed me to come out here I know you
are the most popular man in America
right now so for you taking the time to
do this truly means a lot thank you I
learned so much from you I feel like
every single time I hear you speak and I
know that there are some people rooting
for you but I promise you
it is a number that you cannot even
imagine so many people are behind you
and I love seeing Colorado do well and
you do well well I'm proud of you too
because not only your assistant in this
business that have
just elevated but your class thank you
and your comfortability with whoever and
the moments are never too big for you
you know you know and I love it because
you are exceeding all thoughts because
usually you know when they fly looking
like this substance oh that's a laugh
thank you and you have been consistent
in who you are and I'm proud of you that
means so much God bless you go girl
cause we are Monument I can't say no
moment there we go baby
thank you coach thank you I appreciate
your time awesome and these are yours oh
yeah finding out
foreign